[Music]
Ski Center here in I try to keep the
talk very technical I will not show you
any line of code unfortunately but there
will be a lot of diagrams and I hope
that after after this talk you will get
some intuition on how neural machine
translation works yeah I'm really happy
to share the knowledge we we we have in
in Samsung and recently we have taken
part in neural machine to machine
translation competition so there's a lot
of things going in Samsung around the
machine translation so what what
actually is neural machine translation
and so it's like end-to-end translation
done using neural networks right
so by end to end I mean it's it's a one
monolith right so the the model takes
the sentence in one sentence in one
language and outputs the translation in
the others so so does the training run
before we had a like phrase based
machine translation where you have to
bother about learning separate language
model separate translation model word
class model reordering model and then do
some smart Vicky McKee at the end to to
build up optimize translation system
here you don't bother you just put the
training parallel corpora and get the
translation model at the end so it's
like basically the idea is to the neural
network first takes the input sentence
in the source language encodes it to
some kind of
real-valued representation and some like
to say it's like interlingua and then
starting from this representation it
decodes the output sentence in the
target language right so is it already
human translator level well you can see
that the improvement in the in the
previous technologies like phrase based
on syntax based statistical machine
translation did not improve greatly
recently right and and the neural
machine translation which started for
good in 2015
really goes forward significantly right
but I would not say we're there yet
all right so so that there are simple
language pairs like Spanish and
Portuguese which are let's say easy to
translate but there are when we go to
the European Asian translation there are
much more problems like there is no
spacing or funked Asians in in Japanese
or Chinese right so it's not human level
there ok so this was a big picture and
we will gradually go down to the level
below and below so how the model encodes
the input centers so a sentence is a
sequence right so the natural way of
processing the sequence in neural
networks is ricky-ricky recurrent neural
networks so it was the first the first
what came to the might of resources so
we have a recurrent neural network that
come processes the input sentence token
by token updates its internal state is a
hidden state of recurrent a recurrent
Network
and after processing the whole sentence
the last hidden state of the recurrent
Network is let's say a vector that may
say summarizes the whole sentence right
having this summarized vector you can
start decoding so decoder is another a
recurrent layer that takes this
summarized vector and outputs token by
token tokens in the target language yeah
so it it takes these the this vector as
a context takes what was the last
decoded token to know where where it is
in the translation and outputs outputs
the the next token in the target
language right so this way it decodes
the the D tokens until it it gets to the
end of sentence token
end of sentence token right so this is a
it this was the first model one of the
first models proposed in the neural
machine translation and it works
reasonably well but you probably get the
intuition that having a one vector that
summarizes all the whole sentence is not
the best idea and you're right okay so
it works for short sentences but it gets
poor with the longer ones right so the
next step in the evolution of neural
machine translation was encoder decoder
with attention so human does not
translate reading the sentence
remembering it and generating the output
right it it
read human read the sentence knows the
context and then goes back to the source
sentence and translate part by part and
this is what attention does yeah
so so now we do not remember only the
last state of the encoder but we
remember each each state while decoding
right so we we have a bunch of of hidden
states of the encoder and we call them
annotations and now the decoder starts
decoding but he knows the current state
its current state asks the attention
mechanism it's like they this this
little plus sign is the attention
mechanism it should be probably bigger
but anyway a decoder asks the attention
what what part of the source center zone
which tokens are most of most importance
right now for decoding so the attention
computes for each annotation a weight of
how how important it is in this current
moment of decoding so and then the all
whole annotations are averaged weighted
by this this attention and input to the
decoder so it it knows which word or
talking to to decode so each time it
generates an output its updates its
state asks in the attention what now
what's what's important that this
particular moment computes the current
context of the decoding the attention
puts this context to the decoder and the
decoder computes the output and so on
okay so we're switching to the
next level right so so more more details
I said that the encoder is a recurrent
neural network one layer of recurrent
neural network and in fact it it usually
it is more complex it takes two layers
so there there's a one layer one
recurrent layer that consumes the source
sentence from the beginning to the end
and a second recurrent layer that
consumes the input sentence from the end
to the beginning and those annotations
are all talking about is concatenation
of the hidden states of the forward and
backward layer so now you can think of
this annotation of this concatenation as
a more complete representation of this
particular token so the before word
layer the forward hidden state holds the
information from the beginning up to
this particular token and the backward
backward hidden States holds the
information from the backward to this
token so there's so this annotation say
encodes the information about this token
in the context of the whole whole
sentence right okay so it it was a state
of the Arts last year but probably many
of you remember that the most popular
image in presentation about image
processing and convolution networks was
something like this I saw this image in
all presentation so we need to go deeper
right so the in neural machine
translation it goes the same way so why
only two layers when encoding yeah we
probably can stuck more of them too
compute more structured representation
of the of the of the sentence right so
we can stack that this is the the B you
need unidirectional stacked encoder so
those are the beasts to forward and
backward layers I showed you before but
split it here's this concatenation and
then you use stack next recurrent layers
that process the concatenated
representation but you can also think of
this so you have the forward layer and
you stuck an extra current layer but it
processes the already processed hidden
States in backward direction so it's a
let's say holds the the sequence order
better than the approach on blue on the
left so you process the first branch
process forward backward forward
backward and so on and the second
tranche processes the dissenters
backwards forwards backwards four and so
on you concatenate those states the
structured representation at the end ok
but this was the second most popular
image in the presentation about image
processing they they always looked for
some more depth and here in your machine
translation the same there is another
level up of that in the translation
models and this is why a single
recurrent cell has to be simple it may
within each cell the hidden state may be
computed by several layers building a
hidden state more more complex and
structured representation so so each
cell is
in itself in itself it contains several
layers and the current happens after the
structured representation is is computed
okay so it was the the encoder and the
same goes with the decoder right so I
said before it was just the the bottom
the bottom layer so as I told you before
first the decoder takes the previously
generated token asks the attention
mechanism to compute the current context
and then outputs the updates its hidden
state and outputs the the the next
output right so why not stack more of
such layers up upon this one right so
there is variety of of ways you can do
this you can stock exactly the same
layer with attention and on each level
you can compute the attention in new you
can share the attention you you computed
before there is many many different
reports the the one we we used was the
concatenating the attention from the
first layer with the output of the of
the first layer of recurrence right so
it improves the results of the quality
of the translation significantly but
there's no free lunch right so it comes
with a price and the price is the models
gets heavy right so the number of
parameters grows significantly and does
the training speed drop down right we
have we have done much in the field of
parallelization of the training so after
several months we could go down from
several weeks of training one model to
several days right using
Alti GPU and Python by the way but I'll
get to this in several slides okay so so
what's next in your lost in translation
up to now we train the the D models
using the maximum likelihood so we we
force the model to translate exactly the
same way as we had in the training data
but that's not true right
you can translate a sentence in many
different ways and every every way might
be good right so this is unsolved yet we
should explore new architectures right
less heavy more compact there is I
showed you only the recurrent approach
right but it is it's then it tends to be
slow right it has to process the
sequence one by one yeah it's it's
harder to paralyze then let's say
convolutional networks right so that
there are already approaches called a
self attention and convolutional
networks for translations all those are
interesting and should be evaluated to
see if they can offer the same level of
quality as the recurrent networks of
course we have to optimize the training
in decoding time now it's quite
important when you think of deployment
of such system there is of course
multilingual machine translation right
so up to now you had to have a model for
a direction so you have a model for
German to English and another model for
English German it scales very poorly
with the number of languages right it's
scales in square so if you are thinking
of covering 95% of earth population that
speaks more or less 45 languages having
45 times 44 Mobile's it's it's a bit of
pain so the multilingual approach
trains a single model that can translate
many languages into many languages right
there and of course that translation
right now you think of translation as
stressing translating single sentences
right but the translation should look
completely different
if you translated a dialogue or a
paragraph right and where is Python it's
why I'm here
all all that I was talking about was
done using Python so we used the na
mattes framework that is developed in
Edinboro by a group of machine
translation specialists and they they
work with Tiano
I'm not sure if you're familiar with
with this framework it was it was
unfortunately developed by Montreal and
like four weeks ago they said it will no
longer support this it's like a year of
support but no development but anyway
it's perfect framework for for machine
learning it's a symbolic framework
it has efficient differentiation and it
can be well paralyzed on several GPUs we
use also a flattened framework I believe
it's also a Montreal code it's it is a
wrapper of nickel library from Nvidia
that allows you to do multi-gpu training
it has also MPI so not only one note but
several notes you can you can paralyze
the computation and of course there's a
bunch of other Python codes that do
translations like tensor two tensor it's
it's this approach with self attention
neural monkey and there's a PI torch
that seems to be quite popular popular
recently but I have no no experience in
that one that's all thank you
[Applause]
questions loads of questions that was
the first hand raised
how do you define tokens order a single
word or the bunch of words
okay so III i used the the Vortech and
there was on the presentation a bullet
about this we are not working on the
word level right because working on word
level could potentially make the
dictionaries very large right so like in
languages like German when where you
have words build up of so-called
compounds words targets leaked poifect
or something like that
there's a lot of different worlds so we
use a concept that is called sub word we
statistically divided words in smaller
parts that that we work on right so the
most common words are left in touched
but the words like targis disco echo are
divided divided into separate words one
more so you use features based on
embeddings of these sub words right yeah
so what but you use something like word
embeddings for yeah but its end to end
the there is a matrix at the beginning
of the of the processing before the
entering the recurrent layer there's a
there's an embedding matrix that is
trained
all together end to end right so there
are embeddings but these are not war two
vet or anything you actually didn't tell
us if you use some like task-specific
translation I mean do you try to
translate like everything or do you try
to break down for example that you can
translate like I don't know small talk
or you know asking for directions or
something but in general it's it's not
it's a very good question yeah it's it's
like we have huge corpora that we used
to train a general model but to to have
high quality in let's say common
dialogues or asking for directions or
whatever we tuned the general model with
a smaller corporally you don't have a
big corpora for a particular domain
right so you you don't you do in domain
tuning from the general model to the to
the domain model right do you observe
something like for some topics the
translation is much easier or topic or
some help so I don't know I'm asking for
example asking for weather or directions
is is much easier than
none for example like General Charles um
I'm not sure how to estimate which one
is easier if you have good quality in
domain data for training in domain model
it will be good
it depends on on the training data for
that particular domain there is one
question in front so which data sets
would you recommend to start playing
with machine translation and how much
data do you need to get some reasonable
results okay so the question about data
is is hard one right so there is AAPIs
the website AAPIs on which there's
collection of open source parallel data
it's like open subtitles it's the
biggest one I guess so there's a
subtitles for movies in different
languages right he can build parallel
corpus out of those there's a United
Nations corpus there is of quality
really good quality but it's not really
big a good point to start is is going to
the webpages of the contents translation
content contents accountant contests
like WMT and IW SLT and they it's a
annual competition of translating
algorithms they give you some open
source corpus right but you know to to
to to have a big one like sixty million
or 100 million of sentence sentence
pairs you have to do better than just
downloading the open source yeah usually
you do crawling crawling web pages that
have
pages in the same language and try to
align them and build up your own corpus
interesting that you mentioned open
subtitles as a datas metaphor for who
tried yet once the other sites like for
for subtitles other other data sources
yeah yeah yeah we have our own Samsung
okay all right all right
I guess that the last questions might be
answered during the longer break not
this one
so thank you thank you time
[Applause]
you